une connexion lente un débit tout juste
acceptable gérant de cette chambre
d'hôte jean marie n'a pas d'accès au
très haut débit
un handicap de taille pour le
développement de son activité
on est passé à l'âge du numérique et
quand des gens sont coupés de ça et on
ressent une frustration est grande
déception donc sur ce serait vraiment un
plus pour notre clientèle quoi eléonore
est amené à utiliser internet tous les
jours dans le cadre de son métier
l'absence de très haut débit impacte
fortement son activité
le fait d'avoir du très haut débit oui
ça nous permettrait de développer un peu
notre activité on irait plus vite on
serait plus performant on passerait pas
notre temps à attendre les
téléchargement de documents des choses
comme ça oui ce serait ce serait bien
bien mieux pour nous pouilly sur serein
dispose depuis quelques mois de la
couverture 3g grâce à l'installation
d'une antenne mais le déploiement de la
fibre n'est pas pour tout de suite
la municipalité espère accélérer les
choses en se raccordant en très haut
débit proposé par la région avec le
réseau airs cube
si on a de cette technologie on est
tranquille pour quelques années en
attendant l'éventuel fibres dont on nous
promet l'arrivée mais bon d'ici que ça
arrive chez nous avec nos fourreaux qui
conviendront pas autant joué la carte de
sécurité face au retard du développement
de la fibre dans certaines zones rurales
la région décidé d'accompagner les
départements proposant une solution
alternative est temporaire elle a mis au
point une nouvelle technologie hercules
un réseau très haut débit par voie radio
cette offre elle est à destination du
grand public dans les zones où la fibre
ne va pas arriver rapidement et elle est
aussi dans certains cas à destination
des entreprises lorsqu'elles sont isolés
et comme ont pas accès au très haut
débit dans l'yonne cette offre devrait
être rapidement accessible à plusieurs
communes de l'avallonnais de la puiser
ou encore du gâtinais